[Music]
you guys welcome back to the break room
or Daily Show that keeps you updated on
all the nerdy news you need to know
coming up Thor's brother beat Superman
what's possible impossible the boy from
the Miley Cyrus movie I don't know not
today I don't know we know who under van
is do you I wonder man
happy Halloween
[Laughter]
is the break room and you can't stop
eternals too that train is true
plus you guys in case you didn't know do
you know what today is
um it's the day before my rent's due why
would you say it like that because I
don't want to pay my rent but I do
the scariest day of the year oh my God
everyone thinks it's October 31st but
it's actually November 1st you guys it's
Halloween today
why we're dressed up as perfect people
starting with Jay I am here in a random
Mast it looks like an extra out of eyes
wide shut the name was like get him out
of the orgy scene but I'm happy to be
here Fidelio
uh Jessica Clemens I'm dressed like an
angel because I'm the break room
sweetest angel oh and then we have Tommy
back told ghosts and Goulds come out to
play on this special Halloween
day
I'm dressed as a trash bag
[Applause]
I'm dressed as the chat let me make a
comment I don't think this is live can
we turn up Jay's microphone
oh my God and last but certainly not
least we have Brandon Barrick my best
friend ah Hoy mateys you could say that
my character also thinks his ex-wife was
an ugly hag but we won't say that I'm
not saying that because God might find
me on the social medias I know it I love
my wife uh today's Redemption I love my
curvy wife
because it's Halloween our Redemption
today is in honor of this frightful day
for every 100 we raise and super chats
will be providing you with a scary
motivation
um yeah normally our Mondays are very
motivational but in honor of the
holidays I'll give a little taste I'll
have a little twist to them oh okay
that's okay
this is a little taste of it
the night for you to go out into the
full moon with the gang of your friends
a gaggle of your friends go out under
the full moon and howl as loud as you
can rip your clothing off roll into the
dirt howl and then attack the first
human being you see jogging this is my
motivation for you another piece of
paper it says motivate As The Wolf Man
oh
there's a little taste you know in my
area of Los Angeles that happens every
now yeah I just would like to say thank
you to the text message that ask me
which is longer than nose on my face or
something else
I literally just got to text myself as
your personal phone number oh my God
which one of you little I'll be honest
for me it's the nose by a mile and I'm
not even wearing a mask oh I'm telling
you something about the same lifted diet
well this one here is kind of pointy and
just plastic and hard oh that one's
fleshying all right what's the first
story
Jay's really acclimating well to the
break room now I really feel like he's a
teammate once he starts referencing his
penis in the show
Dahlia zalen Sage did say monster
these are Monster rational speeches yes
uh Dracula and then trophies in the chat
for monsterational speeches spooky drags
tracks and trophies Draculas and
trophies you guys it's time for our
headlines
did it sound so Angelic it sounded
Angelic I was about to burp so I had to
like try to stuff it down
it's time for the headlines also I'm
just being Angelic because I'm the
sweetest angel there ever was okay Tommy
we want the course together yeah
oh but the sweet baby angel brought from
the heavens okay so following the
Superman announcement you guys Henry
Cavill is leaving The Witcher and Liam
Hemsworth is to take the spot now as
girl draw
oh now I get the headline thing Thor's
brother yeah yeah I was like low-key s
a little tricky which um I think
everyone has different opinions on it
like me I'm pissed but yeah
maybe some people aren't mad I'm just
irritated we'll get let me finish the
second headline I'll tell you why I'm
upset so Cowboy personally chose to take
this path you guys he said I was given a
choice of which suit I wanted to wear
and went straight for the Man of Steel
suit that one holds the most Nostalgia
for me and the most meaningful shots
fired and I I agree with that I mean it
is longer he's been playing it longer
than he has been The Witcher but I know
that a lot of there's been a lot of Buzz
and rumors about him trying really hard
to stick to like the book material and
how much he genuinely loves The Witcher
and he played and they would like laugh
at him
these stories are unrelated uh camel was
given a bunch of suits for Black Adam
and he was like I want the Man of Steel
one he was given like a bunch of suits
for his time
oh
they were tagged underneath okay got it
okay
back to my first one toss a coin to John
Costa
thank you for saving Halloween John
going back to the first segment that's
why I'm upset with him leaving The
Witcher I feel like they didn't give uh
and I know that when you do have an
actor that does know a lot about the
character the writers are like well we
do we stick to our different jobs our
same jobs are different I don't
understand why he left the greatest job
in the world he gets to do Eight
Episodes
rip let Jack figure five Total Lines the
entire season roach we should obsess it
here that's the reason you would leave
it's something that you're very
passionate about and they're not taking
into consideration like that I don't
trust this they want him to talk more
bro they don't want them oh I will give
you the counter argument Jessica that he
very successfully did The Witcher it's
much beloved by fans by critics people
like the show I feel like he hasn't had
his home run with Superman yet and maybe
he feels the challenge there and he's
like I really want to announce LeBron
coming back to the Cleveland Cavaliers
right Brandon yes that's a great analogy
that I will accept solely based on my
friendship with you Charlie I hope that
you're not leading me down a path of
tomfoolery I mean he did get to give you
all the championship then left again
then came to the Lakers and just as we
see what happens but he lost his hair he
lost his hair and team because all of
them are ancient and decrepit but look
when it comes to Superman again his
manager who is Danny Garcia who's the
also Dwayne Johnson's manager they were
able to persuade DeLuca in them to give
more control of what they wanted
Superman to be and so that is what
sweetened the pot more than anything
because that's why he left the first
time yeah he they wanted him to do the
appearance in Shazam and not pay him his
fee and he was like no we're not doing
that and also I don't like the way
Snyder does Superman he's he was saying
that and so now Superman gets to be
Lively which again I understand you want
to let everybody know the post-credits
scene of Black Adam but also if Amanda
Waller could have called Superman this
entire time why was he The Last Choice
why was the just I know what the comic
books are why why was the just the JSA
your first choice you could have sent a
bunch of villains you don't care about
and would let them die deal with him you
could have called Aquaman so he could
stop [ __ ] fish they can only afford
some and they could only get under the
skin
but so sorry to mix up those two
headlines really quick but that is my
feelings and our feelings about Henry
Cavill but we're glad he chose that Man
of Steel too I love that man of steel
soon and frankly you know that movie
well some people are not the biggest fan
so yeah I I liked it I enjoyed it you
know what else I enjoy
hey everybody I'm enjoying Batman the
audio Adventures whoa second season of
the hit show
the audio Adventures is out now on each
unable Max Gotham City the seating
cauldron of crime and Corruption about
to boil over in the long shadow of
Two-Face and the Penguins combined
criminal might Gotham City is grip with
twin fists of passion and Terror that's
harleen quinzel bodos is a path to her
heart's desire and scarecrow floods the
city with new and improved oh these
nightmares are improved too she fist for
a tale of life and death in Gotham City
starring Jeffrey Wright Rosario Dawson
Bradley Whitford Gillian Jacobs Keenan
Thompson and Chris Parnell from SNL we
know who he is
a friend of my heart Bobby Moynihan
plays the penguin he said in an
interview with TV Insider it's the role
he's the most proud of in his career I
would think father and husband but your
choice stream DC's Batman the audio
Adventure season two now on HBO math
have you heard about Tom Brady I was
gonna say maybe he's going to Tom Brady
yeah because Tom Brady I consider myself
a Christian and a man of Faith Fly ball
by Castellanos that's a home run that's
it
don't apologize to me I'm behind no I
took you guys back to headlines deadline
has confirmed some early reporting that
yeah yeah
oh boy you're gonna no I started I need
a thumb no I'm fine
the angel I'm burping you yeah dude
thank you has been cast to play Wonder
Man in Marvel's upcoming Disney plus
series about the hero plot details are
being kept Under Wraps but then Kings
leaves Trevor slatery will return Dustin
Daniel critten Destin Daniel critten is
also directing some episodes with Nia
DeCosta directing him in Candyman and
helming uh the upcoming the Marvels do
you think we'll get a little Wonder Man
cameo in that film I didn't know this is
going to end with the question sorry I
read it really bad
this is a new uh headline I didn't see
so sorry yeah this character is so
strange yeah it's so interesting we
talked about it briefly on inside Marvel
and I was like it makes because the
storyline which we'll get into about
Vision Quest soon has already been kind
of done and that's where Wonder Man
Plays a big role in yeah I'm sorry the
new rock stars Chatters uh chat said are
we unprepared there's too much candy
yeah I think everybody's all hyped up on
sweet candy nose candy I don't know if
we'll see Wonderland
Shadow casters
he's gonna need a key to the city for
that problem a big key I don't know
we're gonna reopen want this Factory
seeing Wonder Man in the Marvels would
be like strange so marvelous feels like
it could be kind of light-hearted and
fun well the jokey I don't know I um I
don't think they should lean this way at
all but because of Candyman and him and
Tiana Paris being together I would love
to see them again together in this uh
but I genuinely I'm also like Waterman
is such a different character and I just
don't think he fits in with a lot of
things unless it's like the government
owns him too and he's like working for
the government being thrown in because
if he's like an actor what the hell else
he should play himself in the movie he
should be yeah yeah in the movie who
gets Powers
I brought my microphone down
like kind of like uh Johnny Blaze right
not Johnny Place uh Johnny Storm uh
Mortal Kombat who's Johnny Cage Johnny
Johnny
I know Johnny's a very popular name for
these kids Johnny demonic Johnny
Mnemonic yes
I was born in 2002 I've never seen giant
mnemonic uh uh having him play like
himself in a fun way would be very
interesting interesting it's so
interesting it's like I don't I need him
to cross paths with Tiana Paris but I
also don't have a reason for him to
cross paths but also real quick how did
you introduce dude because he's an
Android who thinks he's alive and a
movie star like does the government say
yo we got a little extra vibranium left
over from when we made white Vision so
we just happened to Fashion him into a
black man like how do you explain that
like the government made a black man I
don't think there I don't think they're
gonna this is just me I don't think
they're gonna stick too much to the
comic material because there's so much
with wonder man that has he should have
showed up a minute ago in retrospect to
what he'd shown up in the comics so
that's why I'm like I think they might
just make him like
so I have an actor maybe a scientist and
maybe being the only person that can
because he's supposedly maybe showing up
in uh Agatha House of yeah we've heard
some like rumors that the character
could pop up in different places yeah so
it's like what the hell else I don't
know I hope he just shows up on episode
one of Wonder Man and we can all just
move on
I'm sorry sorry okay so wakanda forever
is executive producer Victoria Alonso
tells us a meaning behind Neymar's name
she calls him uh Namor El Nino I'm so
sorry I probably butchered that you guys
okay
okay you don't need to Stage me oh
you're supposed to say I'm just trying
to say what's happening
for an angel you sure are evil you don't
have to upstage me
anymore
now get on the trash bag the boy was
well he came after you so I don't know
the boy the boy with no love the mortar
will be the boy with no love and I think
because his parents are dead I mean a
boy with no love that sounds like it
I was a boy with no love both my parents
are alive
both mine are dead now let's keep moving
oh my gosh let's keep it moving happy
Halloween when acid and
innate more not to be confused with
anymore responded we haven't seen the
last of those characters which is very
cryptic and I guess he's really good at
answering these questions anytime
between now and the next 50 years
we've seen these characters and I was
like yeah I mean I could have told you
that but also I tell people when it came
to eternals we know it was Marvel's
first rotten movie right but Marvel had
an undaunting task of introducing 12
people in one movie not six twelve and
then you didn't get the full I hate it
looks like I'm stroking off my nose then
you didn't get the full backstory of
them all and yes they did change a bit
of it but it's like okay you got Dane
Whitman who could be going to blade in
the midnight Sun's route you've got Fina
because you got Angelina Jolie you've
got Icarus and all limb he flew into the
Sun but then you got Harry Styles in the
other group of eternals that maybe
another twist it's like if you read the
comics it's a bunch of eternals and so
it's like Marvel's casting everybody
that are quote unquote celebrities now
what about someone who's trying to get a
blue check mark that would be me I need
to do something I've been here I'm not
paying I'll just verify me on Instagram
but I mean I'm just saying I'm like
they'll come back they'll come back and
I think we'll start seeing them pop up
one in each movie
you know what I'm saying that way you
can spread them out it's one in each
film
we summer made a good point was it you
did about uh some some weapon being made
by fastos like you could introduce there
was a no it wasn't me all right never
I just assumed someone said your trash
bag problematic uh we're one dollar and
forty three 44 cents away from a
motivational job what did you say
someone said that your trash bag is
scary I'm not a trash bag oh they say
it's scary I'm the king of New Jersey oh
yeah that's scary because he is merely a
mirror of them that's right the fear in
their own Souls
the chat boy from New Jersey we're very
close to doing a monstrovational speech
uh the MJ 2997 sending a Super Chat
don't care about all this fandom okay
wrong show just wanted to send in some
candy corn love the most malign candy
here's the deal what if here
in your New Jersey character no it's not
here's the deal with candy corn stuff
it's fine you're from NorCal
but if I was Shasta Lake sale
yes
sorry thank you all soda candy weird
Vibes on the show on Halloween I think
we're haunted today
Christian unpronounceable saying
trick-or-treating I just want to make
sure we're good
well-rounded mom sending in a Super Chat
saying from us moms you're welcome now
clean your room oh that's from three
days ago rounded mom that was an old one
but I'll give it to you well as we've
been talking about deadline has
confirmed the reporting that the
upcoming serious starring vision is
going to be called Vision Quest for now
but they did provide a few more details
in the article about what the series
could be about uh the writer's room is
opening up this week uh and the show's
gonna be about Vision trying to regain
his memory and Humanity remember this is
white Vision who was
put together from the parts left over at
sword lacking the organic material if
you will of regular vision and then just
before
imaginary Vision I don't know what we
call the vision that Wanda made Wanda
made Vision downloaded a bunch of
memories into them and they freaked out
and flew off so it's gonna be about that
uh Jack Schaefer who was the writer on
wand division yeah chaos will serve as
the head writer for this nice congrats
Jack yeah yeah uh do you want to do a
conservational speech I would like to uh
this is a motivated as a ghost oh God
here we go you are a ghost in this city
yes okay
oh
learn from my mistakes don't go to the
Grave with any regraves this is red
right oh I tell that boy or girl from
the office that you have feelings for
them screw HR they don't care no leave a
flirty message on slack wow always take
time to look at the Sunrise after a
night of deviant party wow
don't call relatives that you don't
really care about don't tell anyone you
don't love that you love them there's no
sense in lying tell your uncle he's an
[ __ ] all right
now let's motivate a little more
I'm a ghost so I watch most of you sleep
oh okay I know a lot of you have half
written journals full of ideas that
you've never finished complete that
project okay finish your Manifesto
fish
your Ransom notes finish
him finish yourself off
you can't jerk off a ghost
currently running a jack on weather or a
poll in the chat on whether or not that
was actually motivational yes yes
that's storming that's uh you know
overwhelmingly that could be uh a
standard deviation error we don't know
about that uh so this this visit Vision
Vision question what's the name I love I
love yeah it's a working title for now
they might wind up changing it but it's
also as we've kind of mentioned before
it's it's a story arc that exists in the
West Coast Avengers run uh that several
element elements from the one division
TV show were based on the like made up
kids uh uh a little bit of like you know
Vision losing his memory and all that
kind of uh kooky stuff
um and that that run in the comics also
included Agatha Harkness uh being a
puppet of Mephisto to like help steal
Wanda's kids that wasn't confirmed on
One Division we thought of for a little
bit but they never really dropped the
Big M word she clearly had some
connection with a demonic Force she had
seen or scratchy who was yeah not shown
to be a demon on the show but was
definitely something conceptualized to
be a demon that cut that scene but it
did eat a bug in a very demonic way uh
so yeah those are all things
there's a little as we've said like
there's a lot of Vision Quest stories
from the comics already in the like
Wanda Vision show two to one people said
that was motivation oh okay well then it
was it was technically folks I do it for
you okay
I show up every day to this job for you
do it for the people I'm a man of the
people
freaky people
but here's a question I have for you
guys let's get it out so
run in the comments like vision is
stolen by Shield which obviously doesn't
exist anymore and like in the show our
white Vision was made by sword so how
could how do we think this show could
tie into like other series that are
coming out right we have like secret
Invasion armor Wars even the secret Wars
movie Jay I don't think any of the ones
that we know of is gonna time too okay
and either ones that we know about right
now
I think we are going to set up either
the West Coast Avengers or Young
Avengers this is the jump off point
forward somehow someway he gonna find
those kids
he gonna figure out those kids those
kids exist somewhere I just want my kids
I just want my kids you know some
Visions trying to be a good dad to get
custody and everything he want to you
know play ball with the kids read and
paint and everything I shot a kid I
don't know if he want to shoot kids all
right okay so but I think this is the
jump off of that and I think we're gonna
start pulling or get me straight to get
through this you're almost there I think
he's gonna start pulling their pool like
from different other parts of what comes
forward in phase six
because I think everything that we know
now secret invasion is filmed I don't
think Ravens is showing up he's not
gonna show up in there yeah armor Wars
that's gonna be it's just a movie quick
little movie now it's not even a series
anymore my poor armor so like they was
like Don Cheadle and armor was just
gonna be one of those little kids flip
books
but I think we just like we get him
trying to figure out where the kids are
and then you know somehow some way we
get Wanda though I think she comes back
you think we'll see Wanda Envision we'll
see a small bit of her somehow which
Wanda I don't know the one that had her
living vibrator down and she killed
everyone she snapped out
that is literally think about it
and oh
Percy her sentient vibrator died and she
couldn't handle it guys first of all
this is a family show
who's family though who's family the
Manson family
[Applause]
no
they don't know my uh wouldn't my vision
be the worst dad to teach you baseball
because he would teach it like an
encyclopedia would teach a baseball it
would just be all the facts would he
have white pride
I can't answer that question whoa why'd
you look at me I don't have pride in
anything
come on
that's the part of me that I'm happy
about but I'm not allowed to outwardly
celebrate that
but as the black king I have to say I
Ruled with a tolerant an accepting fish
this is deep water this is too deep for
this crowd someone said this is their
first stream and I'm assuming now it's
been away so you don't think no no no my
vision and sword or in secret Invasion
no I think this is all about just
letting you know scrolls are deep in our
society right and we may get a couple
super Scrolls they might mention it
maybe a yeah because he knows about
sword yeah yeah he knows about sword so
I don't think he is going
where was it
videos
four days before
I think I don't think vision is gonna
actually care about the children and I
don't think he's gonna have any contact
with the kids because he doesn't have
that wow he thinks he meets and unless
there's a vision sorry I'm interrupting
your doctor completely you can only
interrupt it when you go
unless he's like trying to be like I can
become a man if I put these elements
that's that's the thing I could be a
real boy if I get Wanda and I get the
key that is a piece from the comics that
I do really enjoy that which is horrible
to say but like I like that he was like
at one point he was like I don't have
any connection to you Wanda or these
kids because I am not that Vision I am a
different person now and so I like the
idea of that storyline going over and
him being like either honestly I have a
new family this is Vision at the strip
club now all of a sudden he's trying to
make it rain
that that's what you want to see though
right no you don't want to see Bishop
like what's the champagne room like I'm
gonna say get out of there you [ __ ]
robot and someone I think I want to see
him just like on a quest to kind of like
find what makes him him and the people
chasing him or the government they're
like this is my body like you belong to
us we don't care what you are because in
one division they did make him kind of
like Vision touched his forehead and he
was like I Envision and flew away right
so I think by proxy he did just get the
brain waves in the comics it was Wonder
Man but I think he got like the brain of
Wanda so I think he's like still like oh
this [ __ ] is ruined I'm gonna fly away
because that was a vision made by Wanda
yeah a white Vision yeah so it's like
she's now that's why I'm so confused
about Wonder Man because I'm like she's
not gonna have that connection to Wonder
Man like they did in the comics it's
gonna be directly connected to her which
is also part infinity stone if we
remember because Wanda's Powers come
from the Mind Stone yeah yeah and so
that was one of the key elements that
white Vision was missing you know that's
how Vision had his Humanity because of
the Mind Stone more than anything else
remember that when he was in Age of
Ultron the movie that now everybody goes
back and watches right when Thor
electrocuted the Cradle so that's he's
like he possesses the Mind Stone he can
keep it so now you have white Vision out
here like there's something missing to
me there's a hole inside of me I need to
fill this hole and so Vision tried to
fill that hole a little bit by poking
two fingers in him and sometimes you
just gotta
no yeah
go past that but no
what Vision gave him like you did say it
gave him enough right but now he wants
to fill in the other pieces because
again that ship of Theseus do you exist
do you not exist are you in this or are
you out this it still puzzles him are
you the same man are you the same man
yeah I agree with Darnell in the chat
who asked do you think Vision might turn
through the dark side I genuinely am
like this vision's gonna go bad is this
like this Vision your typical Ai and
also and I I'm so sorry it's kind of
have a spoiler we talked about inside
Marvel and Mt brought up a really good
point that uh Wanda's chaos magic so
that chaos magic is directly put into
white Vision which can only mean bad
things so unless he gets like the little
black fingertips
so what burnt ends yeah yeah do you
think we could get this Vision Quest
show before the end of phase six like
before Secret Wars
well if you don't have this show before
then how how do you have white Vision in
well involved at all yeah we could
because here's the thing this just came
out this just came out now they could
flip this in a year so yeah I'm saying
we just found out the writer's room is
open we don't know how many people have
been cast already we don't know how far
into product that's the one thing about
these announcements when they drop on
Deadline variety and all the different
trades we don't know how far they are
into the production we don't know the
full cast we don't know the full story
they know these things so maybe he fits
in somewhere there's a drop could be a
special presentation could be a very
limited series it doesn't have to be a
long expensive thing with you know with
Wonder Man so we could probably get six
episodes something that introduces them
shows you where he is to the point boom
then we like okay where do we see him
and see rewards because that's going to
be something where everybody who's still
alive is going to be in and my
conspiracy brain thinks that they make
this announcement because in secret
Invasion we're gonna have at least a
mention of white Vision or like by the
end of that series secret Invasion by
the end of that series they're gonna be
like oh we've wrapped up this scroll
drama but we got to go find white Vision
because he's out there doing God knows
what the thing is I like to see I like
him showing up in secret Wars and being
on the bad side of things and kind of
playing what Ultron was in the very old
um secret Wars and just being like the
mechanical robot that just kind of [ __ ]
everything out I'm talking like old
comic book old secret ones like the one
that he flew up and was like I'm
freaking out
that is some wacky old comic if you like
wacky was like yeah peace
and my Doom's like I'm I'm I'm uh I'm a
Kang and Kang's like you're nothing you
adorable little baby boy oh you're not
you're not me but I like I yeah I like a
bad vision and they could still go along
with the storyline in the comics of like
even pre Vision that went crazy and kind
of almost killed everyone in the world I
think they could still go that route of
maybe but then he'll be just turned into
like kind of an Ultron which I guess
isn't maybe that bad of a deal it's like
the what if Episode it's like what
happens if he succeeded yeah and
technically vision is part Ultron yeah
yeah when you think about because
remember the original Vision the code's
in the code is in there the code is
still in there so he has a bit of Ultron
in him that's just suppressed we all got
a little bit of electron in us and if
you're like me and you went to Atlantic
City in 2011 you got all it all tried in
yeah you got a lot of it
I don't get it what were you betting on
hooked up with Ultron oh okay okay
all right there's also in in Infinity
War remember Sherry was pulling out his
brain like trying to separate it from
his body and they kind of abandoned it
and he goes out and fights but what if
she got enough
that white Vision could go to wakanda
and be like I need these files oh I
don't know if they're gonna let him just
fly I don't know if they can stop him he
can just space right through well he's
rightful you gotta remember he's
vibranium I gotta take this off
so many trash bags on folks no I have a
full uh clothing underneath
full clothing but you know that like
vision is vibranium and so of course
wakanda can stop anything so he just not
can't but you know I'm saying bargain
like I need to holler Shirley real quick
could he could he face to the ground and
then come up through he probably could
but then they would change it and figure
out how to stop that immediate I wonder
where it is a big question of where his
curiosity is gonna lie at the end of the
day is it gonna be going to wakanda or
is it maybe even just like reaching the
end of the world where we see uh what's
his name Adam Warlock or maybe he runs
into the eternals or like in the comics
he's picked up by someone that like
destroys him so but I I guess we just
won't know we don't know now there are
some rumors that Wanda could show up in
this if we do get a Wanda in this Vision
Quest series who we think it could be is
it 616 Wanda who is somehow unread
poofed herself from getting squished or
perhaps as is it A3 like a deal struck a
deal with the devil return to her with
Mephisto is it a38 Wanda coming in for
Revenge 838 would bring in divorced from
her her vision but falling in love with
white version that's the thing a38 would
bring the kids in right for sure but 616
will remember the whole rule of thumb is
if we don't see a body yeah you're not
dead or is it is it Tom to Max the time
to maximize that shows up are you going
to marry white Vision naked with the
trash bag
perhaps I mean we remember that Wanda
famously told Dr Strange in the trailer
and in the film like this had his
theories about the multiples is this
white Vision gonna search the Multiverse
we're in the Multiverse Saga right well
we start getting flashbacks of that
conversation
oh yeah of the conversation about those
Multiverse because then it'll explain
how much Vision told her about instead
of just the one little thing because
remember she just knows the dark hole
with that shoulder he she knows that
America Chavez opens up portals to give
it a different dimensions and universes
but Vision knew something else so maybe
we get a not a lot just a little I know
what Vision knew he knew that pizza Papa
always gets paid that's right and always
gets laid you don't have to make it like
that I like when Jay makes a joke
so as I mentioned like Jack Schaefer is
going to kind of be I think she's gonna
be the head writer on uh this Vision
Quest series we're starting to get
little like factions within the MCU
right yeah Ryan coogler's got Black
Panther and he's producing the ironheart
series Dustin Daniel [ __ ] you know he
he made uh shangshi and we'll get to
make that next film he's also producing
Wonder Man he's gonna direct a couple of
those episodes and he's directing Kang
Dynasty is Jack Schaefer starting to
form her own little man attraction here
MCU Outlet I think that's what it is
though I agree yeah it's like they find
the people that they like that are doing
a great job and they're like here have
more of this take these stories you do
these stories it's so interesting and
they're kind of giving like Waldron and
loveness these kind of like you know uh
Waldron got to do uh Loki and then
worked on multiples of Madness and is
now riding on Kang Dynasty right
yeah yeah then she has She-Hulk and what
else does she have because she's
somewhere else around there I think she
worked on Miss Marvel a little bit I
might be wrong about that I take that
back I take that back completely yeah
we're getting these little factions and
it seems like they trust Schaefer with
the kind of vision Wanda area a little
bit so yeah I said give her more good
stuff we all loved one division yeah yes
and you know what else we love oh hell
yes we love athletic greens yes we do I
got a bag of it right over here I'm not
gonna lie they sponsor the show sure but
I drink athletic greens every day almost
exclusively a little scoop of AG one and
some water and that's all you need uh
you get your daily nutrition in one and
easy and tasty drink I actually think it
tastes good I think it's sweet it's
delicious yum you a lot of green drinks
they taste green Brandon and I got a
little cat fight yeah you need spit
athletic Greens in my eye yeah never
been healthier my all my medical labs
came down came back better
high quality vitamins minerals and Whole
Food Source superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens it's really hard to read with
one eye this special blend of ingredient
supports a lot of healthy stuff
including better sleep quality better
sleep quality and mental Clarity and
alertness let me just switch eyes there
we go oh it's so bright ag1 is the one
thing you can do every day to take care
of yourself reclaim your health and arm
your immune system with convenient daily
nutrition it's just one scoop in a cup
of water every day that's it you've all
got water coming to your households
lovefully uh to make it easy athletic
greens is going to give you
yes you free one-year supply of immune
supporting vitamin D and five free
travel packs with your first purchase I
love the travel packs they're very easy
to take around absolutely when I go down
to Disneyland all you have to do is
visit athletic greens.com break room
again that is athleticgreens.com break
room to take ownership over your health
and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional Insurance have you ever
gotten some free swag at a trade show
only to immediately throw it away due to
its poor quality yeah I know I have make
some swag that matters we want to we
want to really make some swag the
matters here create an extension of your
brand that's ready for anything with
custom apparel from lands and business
who we thank for supporting the break
room today and sponsoring us get fully
customized clothes accessories and
promotional products featuring your
logos and colors elevated by Decades of
experience they offer timeless style
that fits every body type and I like
that you know fit everybody tights
banging bodies cursed bodies ghostly
bodies hostly by Oh I thought you were
just gonna say whole bodies they got the
widest rate I know nobody that can't say
nothing
much
[Music]
all right anyway they offer timeless
style if it's everybody type including
Keith sweats with the widest thing the
sizes you'll find in Brandon apparel see
your logo and Vivid colors on t-shirts
how to wear hats mugs water bottles and
more hundreds of products perfect for
any trade show event or holiday gift you
hear that new rock stars holiday gifts
they have customer service that goes
above and beyond every business is is
treated like a VIP and when you have
five whether you have five employees to
500 and you can set up an online store
bye Riley bye Bubba where employees can
order items they need without worrying
about inventory see why thousands of
companies count on lands and business go
to business.lands end.com slash podcast
and use the promo code podcast that's a
different code okay for 25 from our
usual I'm serious I'm not joking there's
a different code if you want to use it
it's podcast not break room not the
order I'm not even gonna say the other
code podcast
for 25 off your first product that's
business.com I'm sorry business sorry
business dot lands end.com slash podcast
promo code podcast for 25 off your first
product I'm sure we have that link in
our description yeah it's definitely in
the description great sorry about that
everybody you do know me we do have to
do another Super Chat before we get into
we do would you like this yeah yeah yeah
uh we did raise another hundred dollars
of super chats to give you a month's
division of speech uh thank you all our
super Chatters Jay H begging for a job
out there uh maybe you get Tommy's job I
don't know yeah you can sign up for
Thursday
all right we're actually currently
hiring at ears Jesus thank you Quentin
thank you Tyler Tyler here's a here's a
treat how about a treat motivate as
Medusa oh give them a Medusa motivation
okay
does your father not like you because
the boys like you oh does your father
think you can go ahead and turn everyone
into stone turn them Stone in your heart
and you know what make your own path
turn everyone in you in the Rocks walk
all over them and stand strong and firm
if you want to have sex with people make
them close their eyes oh okay well I
always do that
make them look for the rock hardness
within themselves
make the snakes Slither into their soul
and savory ways down sweetness path good
Lord something else with an S this is
motivating something all right I thought
we were talking about the Medusa from
the WWF back in the day yeah some days
you want to take the women's title and
throw it in the trash WCW when no one
cares about your company whoa
shoots uh I think we gotta get in our
time machine and go back to WCW and
watch them cry their tears
if we're motivated or seduced
I don't know I know we're not allowed to
vote twice but uh it motivated some part
of my body so somebody alert Q Anon
because I'm double voting all right it's
time for mandatory fun yes the segment
that's so haunted we play a graphic
that's vaunted hit the graphic again fun
today wanted
Graphics you know you know uh uh Dracula
Bon Jovi is vaunted
foreign
you down in the coffin I also sleeping I
just can't sweaters
who he is oh you're doing it
you like me nobody
looking body down
please
oh yeah sorry about that it's pumpkin
Peyton time jabroni's we have a spooky
mysterious bucket that looks just like
this bucket but swap the bucket bucket
swaps we swear this is a different book
it's a bucket you can tell because it
says paint on it now we're each gonna
pick out a prompt and then we have to
paint whatever's on that prompt and then
Jessica
we're painting pumpkins there's four
prompts in there each person gets a
promise okay who what was this for to
put paint on okay thanks Daddy
I gotta go just ready all right we're
gonna paint we're gonna talk while we're
painting and then we're gonna reveal and
then there will be and then there will
be a judgment
there will be a judgment
then there will be a judgment there'll
be a judgment but the winner will be the
top pumpkin painter on the break room
and let's add all of the uh the chat
will Judge John will judge Dasher will
have a vote
uh you guys pick your prompts first did
you already go no I just
so well we could start by picking the
players
it's not aggressive if you want the
segment
again do we say what's on the prompt
that we get yeah I thought it was a wee
reveal fine we'll reveal I don't care
okay I'm emotionally dead inside
who broke Tommy uh you know what I just
didn't need to be questioned on every
decision that I made for this beautiful
pumpkin painting contest you did you did
you did tell me what it is
thank you what's what's the scary movie
you're gonna watch tonight I love we got
all these terrifying colors like light
greens pinks purples like are we
painting Easter eggs I don't know did
you get the paint no I didn't
but if I did I would have got better
colors
you're so mad at Jay for what he said
I don't remember what you said
you remember what I said no I'm not mad
at anybody I'm just kidding did you did
you start a timer oh yeah we got five
minutes John five minutes on the clock
it's 3 45 right now so just at four you
already start the clock
oh my gosh uh uh we should shout out
here free girl sent out a Super Chat
saying her anniversary was Friday can I
get a happy fifth anniversary hey happy
fifth anniversary Frey girl happy
anniversary free girl I assume it's
possibly a marriage anniversary I don't
know it could be yeah it could be
anything anything it could be anything
I'm gonna make sure lots of Pinks and
purples go into my pumpkin I don't know
what to paint paint whatever you want uh
do you guys are there any scary movies
you're gonna watch this evening I'm
watching I'm about to try to find
terrifying too on bootleg so I can watch
it because I just watched one now people
say terrifier too is very scary
terrifier one is just a lot of Gore yeah
what is it scary or is it just bloody
it's a bit of both it's a hybrid of both
and so I actually enjoyed it
for what it was worth because I like
horror movies so
I'm gonna watch the second one and see
how that plays out in my life just so
everybody knows these pumpkins will all
be humanely euthanized after the
painting contest so these are actually
these were all very evil pumpkins so
they'll be killed they'll be put down
each of these pumpkins was accused of a
war crime oh wow
Tommy do you like scary movies I hate
scary movies always have I hate when I'm
in a relationship with somebody likes
scary movies I have to be like yeah no
that's chill let's watch The Conjuring
and then they watch it and I am just
buried
scared to death Jessica you like scary
movies
what are you gonna watch
I'm not I'm not I'm I'm do I I
um
I'm going to get together tonight A
little party so I don't think I'm gonna
watch anything tonight okay oh Jessica's
getting her freak on it right I was like
and then I'm helping Tommy give out
Chris Halloween candy oh Tommy you're
gonna give Halloween candy to the
trick-or-treaters
yes once I get my shipment of things to
put in it I will uh lace all the candy
oh so you're out there lacing candies is
what you're saying yeah you're one of
those candy lacers they warn us about so
much John how much time do we have left
because that's one of my favorites are
you guys not like dressing up or doing
anything well no I we we stay inside I
live very close to West Hollywood when
you're in California different ways
Hollywood uh and they do a big party
every year so I have to stay inside
because I get scared yeah it's too
dangerous I'll be listening to the
helicopters all evening
uh it'll be dangerous out there I would
love to go trick-or-treating with my
nieces but they live so far away I would
never get there in time they live in
North Hollywood
they live less than five miles away but
it would take me two hours to get there
what'd you say Jess I said this is the
first year my nephew doesn't want to go
he's 12. my nephew uh one is dressed
like an absolute psychopath that's
normal and the other one is dressed as
Stefan Diggs of the Victorious Buffalo
Bills and while I have your attention
may I mention the Buffalo Bills are
currently the one seed in the AFC
oh John doesn't like it you Grinch this
is thrilling break room content for our
Breakers I am trying to I don't know why
I got so I haven't painted in a little
bit so I was trying to make sure I'm
trying to be focused I'm doing this
solely on memory I don't remember how
much time do we have
okay okay I don't I feel like I'm
putting a hat on a hat here
you know what I can do some
Embellishments our brilliant research
oh please hot takes what's the worst
Halloween candy oh okay uh an apple it's
either
that's a good one it's either an Almond
Joy or a Mounds because coconut is
terrible coconut doesn't taste good I
don't like it sometimes you feel like it
tastes bad what's your what's the worst
Halloween candy
Tommy uh my worst Halloween candy is
payday because it has all the elements
of a good candy bar but then they forget
to put the chocolate on okay I kind of
like the the peanuts in a Payday
chocolate uh whatever those like wannabe
peanut butter type deals is that they
give out the orange yes wrapped up
things yeah yeah I think you have to be
from the Midwest to like that and I'm
from the Midwest and I don't I don't
like it I'm from the Midwest and I don't
like it I'm not an auntie named Cheryl
in my in my street we had a guy who had
a jar of pennies and he would let you
grab a fist full of pennies and put them
in your bag and we always thought that
was like the best but then I let her
realized it was a lot of work for like
50 cents yeah how long did you say it's
a rich doctor 30 seconds
well that's why he was a rich doctor
yeah keeps his money and he spent three
freaking dollars at Target he keeps his
money candy
I'm done by a mile
okay thank you five okay
okay can I get a paper towel yeah
starting from left to right starting
with j ending with Brandon okay everyone
Reveal Your prompt and who you drew my
prop was paint your favorite DC
characters oh that's a good one so I
just started to do the Dark Knight oh
wow yours is actually art okay I started
doing the Dark Nights okay mine was
really hard I got uh paint and
interpretation of a nightmare oh yeah I
[ __ ] with one of you
I drew a monster that's swallowing a
child
mine is paint your favorite horror
character and I did Chucky
I'm Jackie what a play
foreign
just kidding I'm Keith Smith
I had paint your favorite Marvel
characters
I was what I pulled ping your favorite
Marvel character tell me who this is
Iron Man I think that's grungalow or
Eric Cartman in Marvel Studios Red Skull
I think I was going for Iron Man yeah
and then I got panicked and I was like
well maybe I can pivot to Vision
uh but I don't know I mean let's be
honest it's pretty hideous I mean
there's two ways to vote in this it's
pretty hideous you can vote for mine and
be correct or you can vote for Jay's it
kind of looks like Spider-Man a little
bit I guess I got a picture everyone's
looks great this is this Chucky looks
great I wish I would have got choose
your Marvel character I know but if ifs
and butts were candy and butts it'd be
Christmas every day uh yeah
I just want to make sure since we
already seen it I'm just adding a little
details what was everybody's favorite
Josh Allen moment from last night's game
I think there isn't Stefan danger was
pretty great but I also really enjoyed
some of his running place and sometimes
it was like a jazz musician when he
didn't do something it was powerful tuck
the ball in her throw it away
yesterday Smokey the Bear
fragirl Tasha Tasha the MJ 2997 Brock
Humphries he said in a Super Chat saying
what if
vision is the what if vision and looks
for more knowledge and finds them that's
what I got done right there there you go
wow so you did extra time yeah I just
thank you Lord I just filled in what was
what was it mine got six percent
all right now now we're not going to use
the nice these pumpkins I'm gonna go
find a child and I'm gonna hurl this
pumpkin
oh no oh no Tommy's hatching
you said you were wearing something
special doing his best to keep that
nipple oh my God
I'm Batman
free girl we're not fighting keep going
Jesus is he farting he's wearing himself
out Tommy Joe bartoloni says
moment was his two interceptions go pack
go let me guess oh you're a package fan
you lost by 10 you should have lost by
14. they can't they can't hear you dog
Tommy uh uh Packers Fan look at the
scoreboard and then come at me again
but then you know all our super Chatters
today and all our Breakers in roomies
and trash bags eggs hanging out there in
the chat somebody said I know it smells
crazy
strong 12 hours later we're gonna have
to clear out the studio around here uh
but thank you all for tuning in to the
break room today we hope you have a very
happy Halloween happy Halloween remember
folks as you're wandering the
neighborhood this evening getting those
tricks getting those treats the veil
between the living and the dead is never
thinner than it is tonight so be careful
out there because you never know who
might inhabit your soul and take over
your corporeal form hey and we also had
Tommy unofficial breaker I took my
microphone okay unofficial break room
costume contest that's right some
wonderful entries now you guys said in
some of your entries
costume contest oh we have Hopper and
joy oh cute cute adorable oh the monkeys
oh adorable
John you're so miserly with your photos
all right at John Costa if you want to
complain about your photo knife
yes thank you and enjoy your Halloween
this evening be kind to all the kids out
there if you're driving around please
watch out for children it's a very
dangerous night for them and even as
teenagers
especially on uh Halloween's on Mondays
are the most deadly for children I'm not
joking because a lot of people are
trying to get home from work but there's
kids out there so drive safe tonight be
careful be safe have a great evening
we'll see you here tomorrow November 1st
holiday season begins boys
foreign
[Music]